something's about to start on the menu
tonight is a choice of three starters
Sicilian tomato salad hot smoked venison
and lobster linguine Billy wouldn't
Lobster okay no problem to lose in
democracy chequered please chemistry 14
or 16 in greenie of lobster service has
only just started and already I can see
a problem he's going to [ __ ] in there
about five minutes I'm cuz everyone's
ordering linguini but no one's
controlling it check on it takes about a
quarter of an hour to cook each lobster
linguine to cover so much doing linguine
lobster but the linguine in 13 minutes
linguine
if front-of-house don't persuade the
diners to order the simpler starters
Santina will struggle to finish service
within the two-hour time limit I want
three lobsters 1 2 3 a good maitre d
should be able to sell the other dishes
on the menu push the result oh yes
baddest linguine push the venison versus
deliciousness I'm afraid I'm gonna have
the language
as lobster as well puppies in Winnie of
wealth we guess what
how long for the next 4 linguini and
truly widows 6 linguini after that and
with the clock ticking some Tina's up
against it
Jesus Christ I feel for him right now in
there because he's about to explode it's
like an angry you just pulled the pin
he's gonna go any minute now
guaranteed why cause he's getting
screwed upstairs they have to help him
from making his life a little bit easier
than that are they solid in that
delicious venison at 1 1 everyone's gone
but everyone's gonna love them
one more lobster please thank you very
much here we go
for linguini two lobsters please get me
Rocco please
the risottos delicious toast to the
doctor I recommend you to push it for
linguini lobster just for a change clean
the place my darling here we go
two-thirds of the diner's have ordered
the lobster linguine the starters have
taken an hour to leave the kitchen I
spotted a weakness here and it's not the
food is there nice it's rather loud it's
really good
the lobster was lovely nice as mice yeah